sarà sappiamo secondo voci giravano
tanti tipi di spessore allora ho finto
di essere una e mail di me stessa su
instagram quindi una lei speso in
stories mista che ha già creata così nel
frattempo sono arrivato un bel po di
messaggi e ora andiamo a vederli assieme
e andiamo anche a rispondere ad alcuni
filters loro non sanno che sono io in
realtà che vi sto rispondendo ho preso
questa eterna dei video americani e ho
visto alcuni video in cui alcuni fingono
di essere una fan page ed è visto una
che spinge di essere una kate page ho
pensato fingere di essere marini su
facebook perché fingere di essere una
fan page ma magari però anche in altre
lingue di essere una fan page
lasciate un bel live se volete vedere
anche il 55 stesso una pompetta girini e
rex altro a farlo attesi pronti a vedere
cosa mi hanno di cris
questa è la pagina più creando si chiama
odio a il testo visto che non è vendere
organizzatore allora facevano un po
innanzitutto ho pubblicato una foto di
un mio slime prendono affitti o
malissimo
credo all'idea di servizio per fare the
line ma è alta hanno schifo sono i due
live dei concordi femmine in privato
cosa che faccio organica stories è così
perché ho comprato parlare con i glitter
30 persone hanno messo dai che ci sono
75 commenti
allora ha anche risposto marin bari
lista spicca 17 classi come la bordata
giusto
e io rispondo è lei che non dovrebbe
pubblicare video un altro ragazzo
chiaramente non è maicon a lido di pizze
non voglio mettermi a discutere ma anche
una bravissima persona
mourinho ai contro di lei ma faccio una
vita invece di sfruttare le persone
invece di odiarla guerra alcuni dei suoi
video e impara anche che ad apprezzarla
e poi un'altra cosa signorina ci vai a
scuola fai ridere ma è gravissima e
falsa la page non anita è falsa chi ha
fatto la patch non è a vita per cosa la
fenice torre infection
[Musica]
che forse mar interfacce scrive io non
sono d'accordo lite è bravissima ma
questi sono tutti commenti positivi alla
fine allo stallo flames infatti vediamo
crediamo perché fuoco non ha
innanzitutto grazie mille per sony che
mi hanno difeso pensavo di averle viste
tutte brea grandelli imparata grammatica
di secondare al momento ti permettere di
dire cose brutte e stata solo una
bambina che non le piacciono youtube qua
in qualcosa da dire l'affitto valeria
bear 05 e qualcuno gli risponde anche se
ne vale la pena al mato più giusto di
tutto vabbè finora e come ti ho detto
sono super carini però se vedete che c'è
qualcuno che insulta ma solo come
qualsiasi a fa contro una persona ove
insiste troppo contro che chiuderà il
peggio delle cose molto brutto comunque
comunque voi non siete d'accordo non
comportatevi allo stesso modo di come si
sta comportando quella persona quindi
non insultate anche voi perché se non
state passato lo stesso gioco di
bullismo anche se state difendendo una
persona e avete ragione magari non è il
modo giusto per difendersi
con intelligenza scrivere un commento
intelligente e poi la maggior parte
delle volte magari siamo proprio mobili
picco di questi l'intersse quindi
vedersi arrivare così tanti insulti
anche se loro sbagliano appunto da
principio che resterete inviando gli
insulti magari non riescono bene ma
capire la situazione non riescono a
controllare meglio le emozioni magari
essendo questi piccoli che a vedere che
ho a che vedere con le scuole possono
essere le conseguenze non ho figli non
diamo la sua parte di telit è anche
conseguenza dopo fare con l'insulto o
quel commento prodotto chiamo che hanno
lasciato assolutamente difendetevi e
difendete non affrontando ma in modo
integrato sii motivo così spiazzate
tutti come hanno fatto molte persone
interessate queste sfere tutto chiare ma
capire molte cose di come si comportano
le persone però in primo torneo ricevuto
qualcuno ora l'unico più perché lo
patteggiamo posizioni palco e non avevo
tempo per tirare questo video comunque
avevo scritto in una storia scrivimi
cosa ti fa schifo di anita stories in
privato saltiamo e questa ragazza mi
risponde tutto allora rispondiamo le hai
ragione anche a me sopra tutto
soprattutto la sua risata
dopo un po tesa risponde e lei risponde
che alcuni slime li fanno tutti i miei e
la considerazione fanno schifo di sangue
ma non solo al 28 ma non ho detto niente
essendo i messaggi privati privati adro
censurare i nomi poi come di pubblici
non c'è bisogno di censura li avrebbe
stati prima stando ad assicurarli anche
per paura che magari per tutti voi va a
cercare queste persone che fa da karl e
quindi questi nomi verranno censurati
allora stavo parlando con quest'altra
ragazza e disse sai cosa mi dà fastidio
venita stories e league cosa e mise la
sua voce di da un'unica data e la sua
faccia però un'altra cosa
gli insulti i suoi ed che li dato a
figlio quelli che la oggi ne vogliono
far segnalare il canale quelli che non
lasciano in pace mi danno fastidio e le
cose che ha detto prima non sono bene
dic
e tutte le volte che dice ne vogliamo
parlare cruccio è che tutte l'assenza
c'è più che tutte le volte che dice cioè
a te cosa fate schifo
vediamo che la sua voce la sua vita il
suo sguardo eccetera che come fa parte
schifo lo sguardo
allora diciamo hai ragione e poi erutta
di nascosto
[Risate]
concordo soprattutto kg sopracciglio
sinistro nero via cento storico questo
profilo o forse non ti piace non
guardare i suoi video fatto una vita che
brandiva niente lei è bravo e io sono
una cosa quando rispondete na dico sauna
questo team è che io non so dimmi tutto
dimmi le falsità o penso anch'io
e vero è quarta sembra un attimo dopo
meglio fare libro della propria fra le
rapide questa sinceramente ogni clan che
ho fatto non era come quello che faceva
lì secondo me mente sugli ingredienti
che giudizio e poi news
proprio la sua hai ragione secondo me
tutti i suoi e poi d'innesco sentisse
questo commento allora il problema è che
prima era diversa ora fa quasi sempre
oppure apre sempre in gros grain cedo
composto dai premesse miglioli che siamo
onore al riguardo più almeno non come
prima
e anche questa è una critica un po
costruttiva diciamo non è troppo cattiva
non sta troppo insultando sta dicendo
che dividono le tre
ok ragazzi allora ho risposto da alcune
fan per feriti nessuno mi erano tanti
che siano essi un po questa ragazza mi
ha scritto senza non ci cacciano guarda
i suoi viggiano la seguire fatti nomi
che so fare tu fai schifo e risposto no
e le dice vabbè ma siamo così difeso la
pubblicità quindi continua pure a me se
non piacciono youtuber non ti voglio
aumentare evidenziano che baffigo e non
creano almeno una pagina contro di lei
ma come fare e aperti a me piace cosa
c'è di male a te non piace ok ma inutile
che queste cose di pubblicità che
costruisce ma spiegami cosa ti piace di
lei piace davvero
magari mi fai cambiare idea
ora questa ragazza che cosa che ha fatto
sta che è perché è giusto come fare a
saperlo ma all ardenza anche le e poor's
anche lei
vabbè ma fai schifo dubbi scrivo per
fare a gas e lì con o anita e li ma per
favore
ho allora vediamo come fa ma per certi
spiega poi come fai a saperlo
me lo immagino piace di lei magari
cambiare idea decimi che si è mosso come
persona per la sera di un cuore gentile
onesta altruista sempre c'è niente non è
vero tratta male vitale e tu non lo fai
primo di nascosto
noi
una signorina educato e poi maltratta il
fidanzato
siete non piace pacchetto perché normale
che non sa trattenere tutti ma non fare
ste cose adesso che faccio la pagina è
cambiato qualcosa
questa ragazza è un angelo
no inizia sempre la stessa e continua a
fare video come aspetto non è cambiato
niente
troppo brava come sofia certi schemi e
mi risponde perché sa di video
bellissimi ma ne mai 41
sì ma dopo non riesco a scrivere dopo
sono dovuta scappare i bagni emissioni
un'ora cioè detto facciamo
non sarà mai ter una iper sarà esposto
gli ho detto secondo me se ti servi
compra e poi sostituisce di nascoste le
disse ma è sicuro anche perché a me non
è mai riuscito uno stand tutti quelli
che ha fatto quello che gli ha detto che
sono stato in bagno in business e
ridicola qualche mia entrate e quindi
cosa centra povero questa ragazza
interswitch anche se ti punta weafer
identici ingredienti non mi uscivano
comunque e poi non capisco cosa ci
trovino di rilassante nella sua voce non
mi piace vero così rabbia sembra una
cornacchia vecchia e grassa grazia con
sato di pazienza giudizio non ci crede
che a 17 anni difetti a fare queste
bambinate crisi sia mi hai un'altra età
si risponde da uno scritto e ragione ora
è diventata bella questa
l'eroe veramente cioè una vecchia che
gioca con le bambole che gioca con gli
ho chiesto che milioni di più le 17
anche se era uno in particolare
chiediamo troppo
ok come fai a saperlo
non vedo di video parola scritta lo
vedono in video non si fermano che non
sa dirti mi preoccupava live mi dice
dato veniamo pane video o di più ma si
mostra sicuramente il motore di te penso
di sì sì sì a meno che c'è una persona
non guarda i suoi video mi metto a fare
per le per il conto si matura stai
facendo capire capire nel mo perché non
riesco a scrivere che non c'è bisogno
pochi troppo odio nel mondo questo è
riportato tutti questi anzi mi fanno
schifo proprio tutti intero reale
vediamo quali si sono sono in ordine
cronologico sono tutti invece non si fa
perché se mia ragazza risponde che da
ciò che mi sento questo non di sly un
gigantesco e sete di slam tanto tanto si
salvano solo quelli con il vin santo
conferì nomi come fa a questa ragazza
che è troppo brava lei dvd devo dire una
cosa
i fatti sono
una cosa però prometti tutti non dirlo a
nessuno cosa facciamo rimandiamo una
foto che amo impazzendo un video che era
un bravo grazie per le cose carinissima
è che hai detto tml questo non secret e
non riuscire a faccia la verità ma non
dal video ciao stiamo non rimette vuol
dire l'unica cosa che sembra strano ma
siamo davvero noi tra poco vedrai il
video e dobbiamo evitarlo nulla e
montarlo con quei team i lavori in
grazie ai tantissimi pubblico come posso
forzarlo
ecco però che ama troppo la palla
la tua eta che tanti me l'aspettavo ma
non risponde cosa si pensa scrivendo sul
[Musica]
[Applauso]
fortunato triste mio ok le pivot classe
tesoro un balzo che la casta ma siccome
notare che strabuzzato dividiamo quindi
pretende un sacco però sarò anche se
sarebbe troppo lungo facciamo l'ultima
rivelazione all'ultimo persona questa
ragazza carinissima che aveva scritto mi
piace molto
persona ma è una persona di buon cuore
perché leonessa fruita me fatto cambiare
per condire segreto mi può rimandare il
dito che mi hai mandato si è cancellato
come mio nonno più esperti di me ma mi
sa che si può vedere una volta
[Musica]
ecco che riesce a sopportare gente come
te meno nei nostri computer ma io ho
detto no ti dico ok ok i video chiamata
[Musica]
perché quindi mondo la bocca ad ora vale
profit a valentino sono io anita questo
era un esperimento sociale lo vedrai
trabocco su youtube di tempo di montare
i video ti volevo ringraziare per le
cose che ne fosse di metri ma non
possono enorme ma io invece fare anche
in ora esposto con un video quindi
abbiamo ora però volume
[Musica]
[Applauso]
c'è fantastica si sappia che posso
credere mi sono messo a piangere posso
stare due secondi natio chiamata l'avrei
accettata
sapevo che ciao ciao che carriera grazie
per il video a scusa mi sono proposto è
arrivato adesso due stive di torino
grazie pacifiche stretto che poverino ma
si sardo per caso noto un accento di
dove altri 10 sono difatti grazie per le
cose che mi hai scritto davvero perché
allora ho capito una cosa che va online
ciao ciao tesoro che coprono piangere
purtroppo che ha interrotto tutto ma
veramente non so come dirvi quanto vi
voglio bene mi emoziono un sacco vederti
vorrei abbracciarli in forte tutto ma
sapete che a me piace fare chiede lumi
per passare anche tempo possibile con
voi
quindi poiché vista per cosa ne pensate
di questo video se volete che faccia
altri esperimenti sociali scrivetemi
impone miei commenti fuori altri
esperimenti volete che fa e anzi sapete
una ne pensate del video ma abbiamo un
passato enorme ciao ciao triste
[Musica]